une procession solennelle pour les sept
enfants de la famille bernabeu on a
demandé aux pompiers qui ont combattu
les flammes la nuit de la tragédie
d'accompagner les petites victimes vers
leur dernier repos des images qui
laissent sans mots une cérémonie sobre
dont le silence est brisé par les pleurs
de la mère éplorée
alors que le père et brême est toujours
plongé dans un coma musulmans ou non
deux mille personnes ont tenu à venir
dire un dernier adieu
célébrant religieux et dignitaires aussi
voulu s'exprimer
mannarino j'ai célébré de nombreuses
funérailles mais jamais comme celle ci
dit cet homme de foi le cheikh hamza
promet de tirer de ce drame des leçons
de vie la prochaine fois que je
traverserai des moments plus difficiles
je me rappellerai que notre salle 4 ha
est plus forte que moi personne ne peut
répondre à la question pourquoi dit la
vice première ministre de la province
et elle promet à la famille barreau
qu'ils auront un soutien indéfectible de
la nouvelle écosse pour traverser cette
épreuve
oui oui on arrête les enfants barreaux
était apprécié de tous qui les
connaissaient de près ou de loin
ces enfants n'ont pas été parmi nous
longtemps nous avions l'impression
qu'ils auraient pu tout accomplir si la
famille immédiate n'a pas pu se rendre à
temps pour les funérailles
celle qui les connaît le plus au canada
c'est nathalie own and day avec son
organisation nathalie a parrainé la
famille barreaux pour sa venue au canada
elle avait un simple message au couple
endeuillé
oui de l'amour et de la solidarité pour
les jours noirs à traverser car pour les
parents le deuil ne fait que commencer
ici et les à céret radio-canada halifax